manchester airport should be heaving
this time of year
but if quiet airports are a sign of the
times so are travellers
on tenterhooks
until this evening einer was one of them
she's from majorca
a new green list edition she hasn't seen
her parents in months or her brother for
two years
she's now able to fly out for a family
reunion
so relieved it's amazing my daughter
you might hear her but she is jumping up
and down on on
her bed so it looks like the ceiling
might fall
um it is a huge relief it means um
it just it it it feels almost like it's
over
i i know it isn't but it's a huge relief
huge relief the beaches of majorca are
just one of the new green destinations
including malta the belariacs and some
caribbean islands
and there's more good news for those
fully vaccinated travel from amber
countries without quarantine
later this summer i think that the
real opportunity we all have now is to
open up travel through the
the double the double jab and if you
look at it we've got
more than 60 of our population i've now
had two jabs i think 83
or something have had one jab we're
really getting
through it now the crucial thing is come
forward
and and get your your second jab now i'm
not going to claim
that this summer for travel purposes is
going to be
like any other summer as i said i don't
want to
cast a pool over things but as i said
the other day
it will be different but there may be
other blocks to a break
cases are still soaring european
vaccines still trailing
the german chancellor's called for all
eu countries to impose quarantine for
brits on arrival
even though there is reason to be
hopeful the pandemic isn't over
in particular in the world's poor
countries but in germany and europe
we're also still moving on thin ice
we need to remain vigilant in particular
the newly arising variants
especially now the delta variant are a
warning for us to continue to be careful
it's becoming increasingly clear that
the government's appetite for risk when
it comes to this travel list
is still relatively low the priority
perhaps getting the domestic economy
back up and running and while there's a
glimmer of hope for the double jab
many still aren't willing to make those
holiday bookings for fear the rules will
change either here or in europe
and they'll have to cancel and that's
devastating for people like gemma
half the staff at her travel agency are
on furlough the other half
have been made redundant the uncertainty
of the system
compounding this industry's woes every
time a minister says something positive
about travel the phones ring
every time they say something negative
they stop ringing and they stop ringing
for longer
and in terms of what's being announced
today is it enough
it's not enough it's the second last
summer and ironically it's a worse
summer than last year
and and that seems inconceivable when we
have such a highly vaccinated
uh population that they aren't able to
travel as freely as they did last summer
all the new green list countries except
malta will be added to the so-called
green
watch list it means they're at risk of
being downgraded
many are demanding more transparency and
more specifics
for now caution still the order of the
day the wait for carefree travel
continues helena smith sky news